the feud is over Ryan Reynolds
long-standing social media beef with
Wolverine star Hugh Jackman may have
finally come to an end the Canadian
actor posted a new video via Twitter in
which the two silver screen superheroes
call it truce and reveal they've made
ads for their respective side hustles
first up
Ryan's touching clip refused laughing
man coffee company can a cup of coffee
be a superhero his laughing man beans
are born with a special power sure it's
the best-tasting coffee on the market
yeah it awakens your senses with
unbelievable flavor but it also lifts up
communities around the world in the form
of housing and scholarships and he could
be behind such a heroic company you
guessed it my friend
Hugh Jackman the loving and caring man
who created laughing men make every cup
count Wow Wow man that was really that's
really professional it's like it cost a
million dollars
really yeah Wow eight plus for those
excellent hue puns unfortunately for the
Deadpool star Jackman didn't exactly put
in the same thought and effort into his
ad for aviation gin roller rolling Ryan
Reynolds is a complete and total
the June's pretty great thought I'll
have to try it someday sorry man I
didn't think the truce was actually real